كما تابعنا قبل قليل مشاهدينا فقد نجحت
فرق البحث والانقاذ فيها طائر التركيه من
انقاذ ثلاثه اشخاص من تحت الانقاض وذلك
بعد 13 يوما من الزلزال اي ما يقارب 300
ساعه اذا وهذه الصور التي كنا قد تابعناها
واياكم قبل قليل من هاتاي
لانقاذ ثلاثه اشخاص من تحت الانقاض بينهم
طفل مصاب وذلك بعد
قرابه 300 ساعه من الزلزال المدمر الذي
ضرب اجزاء من تركيا
والسوريه الزلزال القوي والعنيف والمدمر
ايضا والذي كان بدرجه
7.8 على مقياس ريختر
وراح ضحيته قرابه طبعا حتى هذه اللحظه
حوالي 38 الف شخص
الارقام تت يوما بعد يوم الناجون ايضا
كذلك يعني
في في ازدياد خلال الايام الماضيه
الناجونه من تحت الانقاذ من تحت الركام
ايضا كذلك في كل يوم نسمع خبر عن عدد من
الاشخاص في عدد من الولايات التي تاثرت
بهذا الزلزال تم انقاذهم من قبل فرق البحث
والانقاذ والطوارئ والمسعفين ايضا
الموجودين والمنتشرين في اكثر من عشر
ولايات تركيه وكذلك ايضا حتى في الشمال
الغربي السوري اليوم ربما هذه احدث
الحالات طبعا والعمليات عمليات الانقاذ
ناجينا من تحت الركام بعد ما يقارب 300
ساعه من هذا الزلزال المدمر اي نتحدث عن
13 يوما من هذا الزلزال الزميل زيدان زين
كلو نقل لنا صوره هذه العمليه انقاذ هؤلاء
ثلاثه اشخاص كما ذكرنا بينهم طفل مصاب وتم
العثور كذلك على ثلاث جثث كانت موجوده في
ذات المبنى الفرق فرق البحث والانقاذ لا
زالت طبعا تتقصف وحاول ايضا ان تعثر على
ناجين محتملين تحت الركاب في اكثر من
ولايه اذا هذه صور لاخراج بعض الناجين من
تحت انقاض هذا المبنى الذي
دمر وانهار بشكل كامل بعد الزلزال المدمر
الذي ضرب
تركيا وسوريه وكذلك ايضا اثاره المدمره
ربما تابعناها قبل قليل مع الزملاء محمود
شكر وزيدان ومن ملطيه ايضا كذلك